hi guys can we get rid of me someone's
in session
[Music]
okay so I have so many new pieces for
Fashion Week
I'm so excited to wear them let's see
first thing I'm super excited wearing is
this beautiful Stella McCartney shirt
and love this jacket from Club Monaco it
kind of looks so simple but there's
something really beautiful about it
quite elegant sophisticated when you
wear it especially this little bit of
detailing on the sleeves this reef skirt
I am just obsessed with its obscure
looks really cute paired with pretty
much anything I wear it with white pages
if you like muted dusty Pink's you can
just think of this it's like a really
simple quite lazy pretty blouse from
whistles every season I try and be very
much me and show off my usual style
which is usually quite tailored I love
tailoring I love to feel quite smart and
sophisticated while also quite elegant
and feminine I like to kind of show my
personality through while wearing but
also make it wearable as well okay so
for accessories I cannot wait to wear
this again this is a little Fendi clutch
bag I want a few times already but not
enough I felt it needed a little go
again for Fashion Week and then this is
just adorable
Kimora London and this one I'm just so
in love with the Dior of about in the
super royal blue my last bag and expect
where is the Louboutin Capucines in the
vanilla pink is so known in the season
our Millah can't wait for more berry the
anaheim our show I love everything
in Topsham unique and always the
favorite and then more accessories so
we've got some sunglasses and love
wearing sunglasses even if it's not that
fun it to be honest
so it adds a little bit more color and
do something a little bit more for to an
outfit
these are favorites and you're ever in
the throng in Havana and then it can't
be another pair of your ever in the
silver the thing with Fashion Week is
it's basically really fun and it's about
being inspired so try not to take it too
seriously as one of I've got a real
peaceful pair of shoes I've got a mobile
battery charger listening you always hit
that meeting like health buy my bags so
if I get like a little bit peckish on
the way I've got some that you have and
they like a little bottled water those
sort of things like be essential shoes a
problem.i favorite setting so these I am
so excited to wear these repair from
Chloe and Clay Bennett I couldn't not
get these I mean the color is just so
pretty this lime icky pink dusty rose
was the coolest like rainbow glittery
effect I don't think it can be a pair of
your photography and these I'll be
honest I think these are probably like
my favorite groups of the whole season
that honestly the most comfortable boot
I think I've ever ever Ward it's
wonderful the amount of cameras and
photographers around Fashion Week is
really cool to see so many creative
people on place so I know that I may get
photographed from here to there
potentially on one day so I guess I bear
that in mind at the same time I also
need to take my own instagrams my own
blood comes in and comes like things
about my own content as well so as long
as I'm wearing things that my audience
will like and will like me in as well
and let's say Chris potential wear them
kind of
[Music]
thank you so much for watching guys
wanna see more videos like this one done
make sure you subscribe down below to
glamour in UK it's gonna see more of me
when you can subscribe to my channel
which is in the fro and I hope you a
week bye